dandy dougherty says she was sexually
abused at the age of 11
and raped at the age of 15 and that her
abusers
were the same age as her consent
needs to be talked about from a very
young age pornography needs to be talked
about from a very young age
it's not inappropriate to talk to a
ten-year-old about sex
it's inappropriate for a ten-year-old to
be watching
fake sex online and thinking that that's
what's normal that's what's bad that's
the bad part
as a parent you kind of you look at your
10 year old daughter and you want to
protect them from all that
you saying that's not possible parents
need to wake up i was sexually assaulted
for the first time at 11. then at 12
then at 13. by a boy's age boys aged 11
and 12 and 13. and how was that dealt
with
i didn't say anything about it at the
time i didn't have the words for it
i didn't understand it this was dandy at
the age she says she was being assaulted
by other children
she's one of many to contribute to the
website everyone's invited
but she's waived her anonymity because
she feels an abuse culture has thrived
through inaction by schools and parents
today the national education union
debated the issue at their virtual
annual conference
this motion is long overdue harassment
and abuse is something all women face
my union brothers the first thing you
can do
is simply believe us the neu general
secretary
is calling for a national training
program for schools to tackle
sexual harassment we've gone back in
this respect
i think that the way girls are treated
on social media
i think the fact that so many boys watch
porn that really has
corrupted the way that boys and girls
think about each other
pupils themselves are asking when does
behaviour cross
from natural sexual curiosity into abuse
sometimes the line is subtle plus the
landscape of interaction
is changing schools and parents are
struggling to keep
up with different forms of communication
but now there's a new
instagram account which invites young
girls to post
abusive texts and snapchats which shows
that all too often
the harassment is blatant the messages
include
threats of rape often when a boy's
advances are turned down
and derogatory conversations like this
where a girl is told
no one is going to rape you when she
replies you saying i'd be privileged for
someone to rape me
he says no you'd be lucky so many of
these young people have felt
unable to tell their school what's been
happening to them
many of these schools think that they
have good roots
people that children can trust who they
can talk to and yet somehow
it's not it it's not always adding up
we've been saying these same things
for years and years and years and it's
taken thousands of people to come
together and say them all at the same
time
loud enough for anyone to hear them and
young women like dandy hope
that by recounting their darkest
childhood memories
tomorrow's children won't have to
experience what they did
jason farrell sky news